[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
mi invitado de hoy es el coordinador de
comunicaciones estratégicas del Consejo
de Seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos
John Kirby Gracias por acompañarnos es
un gusto Gracias
hablaremos sobre varios temas de
política exterior pero quiero empezar
por la guerra en Ucrania
nos acercamos a la fecha que marca el
primer año de la invasión rusa en
Ucrania podría decirme cómo ve la
administración la situación actual en lo
que respecta a Ucrania pero también en
lo que respecta a Rusia
los combates por Back mood en el don
Bach todavía son bastante intensos por
supuesto bakmuth no tiene valor
estratégico para el señor Putin para el
ejército ruso Parece ser un objetivo
personal del señor prigo sin que Sigue
enviando convictos a ese enfrentamiento
Así que esos combates todavía son
bastante intensos en el resto del Sur
Los combates no son tan cinéticos Por
decirlo de alguna manera Pero sí
suponemos que a medida que mejore el
clima los rusos tratarán de hacer más
movimientos ofensivos en cualquier punto
de ese frente Por eso estamos tan
concentrados en asegurarnos de ayudar a
Ucrania a prepararse para todo eso
estamos haciendo entrenamientos fuera de
Ucrania enfocados en batallones con
armas combinadas para batallones
ucranianos estamos enviando vehículos de
combate bridley vehículos de combate de
Infantería striker los alemanes
anunciaron hace poco que enviarán
tanques leopard los británicos enviarán
algunos tanques
estamos haciendo todo lo posible para
ayudar a que las fuerzas ucranianas se
vuelvan buenas manejando las armas
combinadas porque ellos creen que van a
necesitar esas habilidades en campo
abierto durante lo que podrían ser
combates intensos cuando llegue la
primavera Estados Unidos ya ha enviado
alrededor de 30 mil millones de dólares
en asistencia militar a Ucrania por
ahora todavía se está discutiendo el
envío de misiles de largo alcance y de
aviones de combate hasta el momento
Estados Unidos ha hecho que no al envío
de esas armas Por qué no lo quiere hacer
todavía
trabajamos al unísono con los ucranianos
casi todos los días en sus necesidades
para la seguridad y en el tipo de armas
y plataformas que quieren trabajamos con
ellos sobre todo en tiempo real Y a
medida que ha evolucionado la guerra
también lo han hecho nuestras
contribuciones para Ucrania no me quiero
adelantar pero nos Seguiremos
comunicando constantemente con los
ucranianos sobre lo que necesitan para
el combate en El que están y de manera
igual de crítica como lo dije hace un
momento para el combate en El que
suponemos que estarán más adelante pero
la discusión Fue bastante similar con
los misiles y los tanques Abraham al
principio se dijo que no y después hubo
un cambio en la postura de Estados
Unidos los ucranianos han repetido que
necesitan que las decisiones se tomen
más rápido cuál es la respuesta de
Estados Unidos a eso
lo repito nosotros hablamos con ellos
todos los días con solo fijarse en el
ritmo el tamaño y la escala de los
sistemas de seguridad de Estados Unidos
se ve que es algo histórico sin
precedentes a veces el tiempo que pasa
entre el momento en el que el presidente
da la orden de que algo se envíe a
Ucrania y cuando eso llega a manos de un
soldado ucraniano puede ser cuestión de
días eso nunca se había logrado antes
entiendo todos entendemos que el
presidente selenski está en medio de una
guerra intensa su país ha sido invadido
su pueblo está siendo masacrado Por
supuesto que quiere más y que lo quiere
más deprisa todo el mundo entiende esto
pero Estados Unidos literalmente ha
liderado en las contribuciones que ha
hecho a Ucrania y en la convocatoria de
otros países para que hagan lo mismo
como lo hicimos esta semana en Bruselas
por supuesto el objetivo Central es la
paz
Pero esto se oye desde todos los
rincones del mundo en este momento cómo
se ve esa paz y es realista al menos a
corto plazo alcanzarla
dos cosas primero podría haber Paz hoy
Mientras usted y yo estamos sentados
aquí todo lo que el señor Putin tiene
que hacer es sacar a sus tropas de
Ucrania de todas maneras no pertenecen
allí eso obviamente no va a pasar como
no va a acabar hoy nos estamos
concentrando en asegurarnos que Ucrania
pueda seguir teniendo éxito en el campo
de batalla y por Dios en los últimos 12
meses han logrado cosas más allá de lo
que mucha gente pensaba que podrían
hacer así que Y esto es algo que solo El
señor selensky puede determinar en caso
de que el Señor selenski esté listo para
sentarse y tener una negociación con el
señor Putin debe poder hacerlo con
fuerza con la convicción de que la
comunidad internacional y Estados Unidos
lo apoyan debe poder hacerlo con ese
apoyo nosotros nos concentra en el éxito
en el campo de batalla para que él pueda
tener éxito en la mesa de negociación
cómo sería eso Cuáles serían las
circunstancias que estaría dispuesto a
negociar con el señor Putin eso es algo
que sólo el presidente se lensky puede
determinar la estrategia nacional que se
publicó el año pasado se centraba en el
hecho de que existía una amenaza
inmediata por parte de Rusia
pero también ponía el foco en China como
la competencia el desafío a largo plazo
para Estados Unidos
quiero hablar un poco acerca de China
hace poco ocurrió el suceso con el globo
espía chino que fue derribado por
Estados Unidos
los chinos acusan a los estadounidenses
de hacer lo mismo en su espacio aéreo lo
cual Estados Unidos ha negado
pareciera que la reanudación de las
relaciones entre Estados Unidos y China
que empezó con la reunión entre el
presidente biden y el presidente chi
está teniendo un comienzo un poco
complicado
Cuál es la situación En qué estado se
encuentra actualmente la relación entre
Estados Unidos y China
el presidente ha sido muy consistente
Busca una competencia estratégica con
china una competencia que según el
presidente biden estamos bien preparados
para ganar pero no busca conflicto eso
no ha cambiado incluso con este globo
espía eso no ha cambiado no Buscamos un
conflicto con China
y cuando el presidente biden se reunió
con el presidente
xie en Bali hace unos meses ambos
líderes dijeron y pienso que ambos lo
creen que esta es una de las relaciones
bilaterales con más consecuencias en el
mundo y que ambos deben ser garantes
responsables de esa relación
ambos están comprometidos en moverse En
esa dirección al menos lo estaban en
Bali y el presidente biden ciertamente
lo sigue estando es más difícil hacerlo
ahora Dado que los chinos hicieron
sobrevolar sobre nuestro un globo cuya
intención era la vigilancia y la
recolección de información
entonces se entiende porque este no es
el momento más apropiado para que el
secretario blinken vaya y hable con los
chinos sobre cómo hacer avanzar esta
relación al menos no por ahora
ese era su objetivo esperaba poder
hacerlo prácticamente estaban en el
avión listo para irse cuando descubrimos
ese globo espía chino sobrevolando el
país Mire lo repito creemos que esta es
una relación importante y ciertamente
Nos gustaría verla en una mejor
situación de la que se encuentra ahora
pero el hecho de que esté así en este
momento se debe a las acciones chinas
por su decisión de hacer volar un globo
espía sobre nuestro país llegar a un
momento en el futuro en el que será
apropiado que el secretario blinken vaya
a Beijing habrá un momento en el que
será apropiado que se den el tipo de
conversaciones que ambos líderes querían
que tuvieran nuestros dos equipos al
salir de Bali pero ese momento no es
ahora
y hablando de la influencia de China y
de su comportamiento al igual que el
comportamiento de Rusia quiero enfocarme
en el continente africano
hace poco se llevó a cabo la Cumbre de
líderes de Estados Unidos y África aquí
en Washington
vinieron muchos líderes y hubo muchas
conversaciones
Estados Unidos dejó Claro que se trataba
de África no de cualquier otro país y
que el enfoque era la relación entre
Estados Unidos y los países africanos
pero no se puede negar la influencia de
los chinos la influencia de los rusos en
el Continente qué tanto se habló sobre
eso durante la Cumbre con los líderes
africanos
Tuvimos una agenda amplia para la Cumbre
de líderes africanos como podrá
imaginarse se discutieron muchos temas
que son importantes no solo para los
líderes del continente sino para
nosotros y para el mundo porque lo que
pasa en el continente tiene un impacto y
repercute en el mundo Entonces es
importante para todos Se habló acerca de
todo como la seguridad alimentaria no
crea ni por un momento que la guerra de
Putin en Ucrania no afecta la seguridad
alimentaria en el Continente porque si
lo hace
a pesar de lo que el ministro de asuntos
exteriores labrove quiere hacer creer la
seguridad energética de nuevo no debería
subestimar el grado en el que la guerra
del señor Putin ha afectado la seguridad
energética y la oferta y demanda en el
mundo el cambio climático la lucha
contra el terrorismo podría seguir una
cosa más tiene razón los rusos y los
chinos están tratando de influir en el
continente y muchos africanos están
notando que esa influencia esos
esfuerzos tienen un precio para la
población africana
tienen un precio para sus ciudadanos
para sus familias para sus vidas y su
sustento como los prestamos con
intereses altos por parte de los chinos
que de repente algunos países africanos
no pueden pagar cuando Estados Unidos Se
involucra como lo hemos hecho y como lo
Seguiremos haciendo es En beneficio
mutuo siempre lideraremos con nuestros
valores y a eso no se le puede poner un
precio y ciertamente no es algo que
estén haciendo los rusos ni los chinos
podemos conocer alguna información sobre
el viaje del presidente África cuándo
será A dónde irá
no tengo itinerarios o viajes del
presidente para comentar
y Una última pregunta sobre el acuerdo
nuclear de Irán según Estados Unidos en
este momento tener esas conversaciones
no es una prioridad los iraníes parecen
decir que hay intercambio de mensajes
Cuál es el estado del plan de acción
integral conjunto en este momento desde
la perspectiva de Estados Unidos
no hay cambios en este momento sigue sin
estar en nuestra agenda es difícil
ponerlo en la agenda cuando mientras lo
discutíamos meses atrás los iraníes no
estaban negociando de buena fe no
estaban negociando con seriedad sobre lo
fundamental que eran sus ambiciones
nucleares
y estaban tratando de llenar las
conversaciones con todo tipo de
propuestas que no tenían nada que ver
con sus ambiciones de armas nucleares
eso por un lado por otro es difícil que
sea parte de la agenda cuando el régimen
iraní sigue maltratando a su propio
pueblo y violentándolo por protestar
pacíficamente
Así que Seguiremos responsabilizando a
Irán por la manera en la que está
tratando a su propio pueblo Y por cierto
por la manera en la que está apoyando a
Rusia en Ucrania entonces deberíamos
terminar esta entrevista como la
empezamos
Porque Irán el régimen enteran está
ayudando de manera tangible y manifiesta
al Señor Putin a matar personas
ucranianas inocentes que no son una
amenaza para nadie mucho menos para
Rusia
pero al darle cientos de drones con
capacidad letal Irán está asistiendo de
manera directa y manifiesta a Rusia en
esta guerra Seguiremos haciendo
responsable al régimen el plan de acción
integral conjunto no está en la agenda
en este momento
Gracias John Kirby y gracias a ustedes
por estar con nosotros y sintonizar la
entrevista de France 24 quédense con
nosotros a Para más información
[Música]